in the trailer that I watched for crave
Ron Perlman's character quoted like this
old Cherokee saying yeah and it was
interesting and it just said sort of
like you know we all have like two
wolves inside of us there's a good wolf
and a bad wolf which wolf will win and
the old Cherokee grandfather says you
know which one will you feed something
which ever you feed more wins right yeah
how does that apply to screenwriting now
that's a stretch but um I think it
applies to living you know it's like if
you feed the bad side of you that's
gonna win if I focus on what's wrong
with whatever in my day is I'm gonna
have a bad day if I focus on what's
right with it I'll have a good day if I
focus on the problem the problem
increases and I focus on the solution
the solution increases its true with
everything not just green running are
you able to turn off the problem that
much and it's it's interesting it's just
kind of like there's a saying you know
you might the mind is like a magnifying
glass it depends on where you sort of
aim it if you aim on the problem it's
going to grow and if you aim on the
solution same thing so
you